this is who's going to die Avengers
infinity war edition oh it's definitely
the end times so here are the odds on
who will die Rotten Tomatoes does not
condone actually gambling on MCU
storyline before we get started does
anyone want to get out first up the long
shots
Captain America well Chris Evans has
said he wants to step away from acting
and focus on directing but he's signed
on for the next - infinity war movies
seems like you walked away alright it's
not a problem Doctor Strange spider-man
ant-man to Hulk and black panther odds
of any of these characters dying a
hundred to one there are some possible
contenders like Scarlet Witch she's
super powerful but her brother
Quicksilver died and they're really
close so maybe she won't miss earth all
that much her odds 75 to 1 and Black
Widow one of the strongest female
characters ever however she's also just
a human being and Bannos tends to eat
them for breakfast there's worse ways to
go
her odds are 50 to 1 how about the
guardians of the galaxy let's start with
the big guy Drax made it known after
Owens death that he was going after
thanos groot well Groot is of all the
Guardians
it's Gamora that seems the most likely
Thanos basically stole her from her
village tortured her and her sister by
making them fight this thirst for
vengeance definitely puts Gamora on the
chopping block hey star-lord you want to
ask her out he'll know I know now is
your chance to do it putting her odds at
75 to 1 the god of thunder with Chris
Hemsworth contract obligations coming to
a close and no announcement of a fourth
for film it's not beyond the realm of
possibility that Thor's run ends right
here does that like sparkles we're
putting his odds of the next funeral up
at 25 to 1 vision
Thanos once the Infinity stones and
vision just happens to have one of them
in his forehead some of it that is
unless Shuri saves him odds of dying 20
to 1 now we're down to the solid
that ah nebula poor poor nebula Thanos
tortured his adopted daughter by making
her fighter sister and replacing her
broken limbs with robotic ones whoa she
wants to kill her father nebula story
arc could very well end here by putting
her odds of dying and the one who are we
forgetting hmm
oh yeah Hawkeye who in a universe where
heroes have the power vibranium whether
controlling hammers and suits of armor
he's got arrows but for God's sake he's
not even on the poster
come on plus there's a chance that his
death will raise the stakes for the rest
of the Avengers
Hawkeye odds are even you didn't see
that coming another character who could
bite the galactic dust is Loki sighs he
kind of sort of betrayed Thanos by not
leading a successful invasion of Earth
in the first Avengers movie and his
switch to hero back to villain and that
over to hero and then back to villain
could see him risking his own life to
save his brother Thor on the other hand
he's already survived everything
including becoming a human paddleboard
for The Incredible Hulk
if anyone can cheat death it's that dude
but he was in the lowest rated Marvel
movie Thor the dark world at 66% of the
tomato meter will put Loki's odds at
dying
and even finally that leaves us with a
man that started it all ten years ago
Tony Stark this could be a fitting end
for Iron Man
many of the world's issues stem from
Stark Enterprises and trying to protect
the world led to Ultron so like thanks
but no thanks man stopping Thanos could
be a poetic send-off to one of the
greatest MCU characters ever what's in
the trailer Thanos appears to say to
Tony we hope to remember you well put
him at even odds because no one death
would be more impactful than Iron Man
himself odds are someone or someone's
going to be bidding adieu there's only
one way to know for sure
check out Avengers infinity war when it
hits theaters April 27 this has been a
shot in the dark